the new DreamWorks movie home commits
all of the worst sins of animated alien
design I explained how on this week's
episode of angry nerd first your
comments Spencer white away says
beetlejuice 2 was confirmed what do you
think about that Spencer I think I've
been hurt too many times to believe it
until I see a trailer Michael Keaton
confirms and he'd love to do a sequel
someday maybe Tim Burton confirms it
he's kicking around script ideas or
something stop teasing us so by all
rights I should love home the kids book
that it's based on is a boot Steve
Martin lenses voice and the director has
done some great animated comedies but
here's the thing I hate the look of the
aliens in home hate hate hate they are
squad purple slabs with no sharp edges
and no interesting features like so many
CG aliens in you know all ages cartoon
films they're designed to look cuddly
and non-threatening but they end up
looking like boring CAD design blob
Jack's I mean just look at home escape
from planet earth planet 51 battle for
terra also why are they always green or
purple or blue see toy story's cute
simple aliens were funny because they
were so generic and indistinguishable
stranger from the outside imagine if
those alien characters were expected to
carry a feature film it's like the
filmmakers are trying to make their
alien life forms of ealing and
non-threatening like et was but they
seem to have forgotten that ET is
actually kind of squicky and horrifying
when you first see
see / see it ZT have a gender and
where's the HR Giger of cute kid
friendly extraterrestrials the worst cg
animated film ever by several
light-years in a parsec is Mars Needs
Moms and its problems are all down to
its god-awful alien Desi come on look
what were they ah as cute kid friendly
characters they fail but they managed to
loop around to the other end of the
spectrum and become really disturbing
disney slap those characters in a horror
movie and maybe you can make back some
of the tens of millions that movie lost
you know what animated alien Strikes a
perfect balance between cute and
otherworldly and menacing stitch now why
is it still so much harder to do that
with warehouse size render farms than
with a paper and pencil what's your
least favorite movie alien design let me
know in the comments subscribe to the
wired channel watch easy watch these
other videos over there with me and them
my other rats oh stop causing time
paradoxes how many times I got to tell
you you're gonna make the universe fold
in on itself you dimwit